sec également dans ce groupe de tête et
et Denis rou aussi et Jérôme Simon ils
sont quatre Jérôme Simon qui porte le
maillot de grimpeur du grimpeur
c'està-dire le meilleur montagnard
jusque là mais c'esttas maintenant en
haute montagne aux alentours de 2000 m
qu'il faut s'imposer il y a zadrobileek
aussi va falloir s'habituer à son nom
qui compose ce groupe de tê ça n'est pas
le plus difficile c'est s habituer à sa
silhouette qui est celle des hommes
massif élégants une centaine dans Leon
oui Gérard Gérard r avec je vous entends
toujours excessivement mal mais je
tenais à prendre l'antenne maintenant
parce que je viens de me rapprocher de
Jean-François Bernard et puis de
discuter également avec yvzard et
Maurice Le Guillou et j'avoue que la
situation est quand même assez
dramatique en ce sens où Jean-François
Bernard souffre du bas ventre ce serait
plutôt musculaire plutôt que intestinal
c'est-à-dire qu'on pense on ne prononce
pas encore le mot de pubalgie mais on y
pense très sérieux
n bar hier dans les j n plus plus
carèmul et il est question il est
fortement question que jean-fç Bernard n
pas jusquau bout aujourd'hui alors je
pense que nous allons rester avec lui
pour l'instant il a 10 minutes deetard
sur groupe de raort
à exactement 8 que VI don maisès que
j'aur top précis je vous le dirai afin
que nous ayons l'écart exact donc dans
cette montée du
Glandon d'accord Jean-Paul je vous
reçois un peu
mieux avec à l'image Herrera qui a fait
un une jolie remontée mais simplement
pour impressionner moté qui contrôle
tout et dans ces virages là il faut ne
faut jamais laisser Herrera en tête
c'est là qu'il accélère à la sortie
surprend tout le monde Alcala ne sera
pas surpris pour sa part parce que il
est bien tout à fait dans le sillage on
peut plus parler devant étant donné que
le vent ne gène pas tellement en
montagne surtout qu'aujourd'hui sinon
ici à l'Alpe d'est le ciel est très beau
mais il fait un petit peu frisqué quand
même quand on est à l'ombre et Herrera
lui continue à la sortie des virages je
le répète pour surprendre Alcala et les
autres et alors que Cabrera impose un
rythme très soutenu et assez rapide et
certainement quelques coureurs vont être
en difficulté dans c'est lui qui est
parvenu à se détacher déjà tout à
l'heure pour aller chercher Abad et le
Françis
Lecler Roland Lecler et non pas l'ancien
champion de France qui appartient à
l'équipee Roland lecl qui pour Mar Espel
Cara
rens il semble que d'une part on att
l'atque des grappeurs et tous ceux qui
sont chargés d'accompagner un coéquipé
le font
avec cette espèce
d'angoisse à savoir quand les grappeurs
vont démarrer c'est une
étape c'est une étape de pure grimpeur
aujourd'hui car il y a pratiquement pas
de plat il y a trè il y a trois cols de
première catégorie à escalader Lee de la
modeline il y a la descente ensuite on
attaque tout de suite le glindon et il y
a la descente du Glandon pour
attaquer l'arrivée finale ici à l'Alpe
duest je crois que c'est le un terrain
idéal pour les grimpeurs et certainement
ici en haut de l'Alpe du beaucoup de
favoris du Tour de France risquent
d'être éliminé et aujourd'hui au moins
de3 passeront par Jean-Paul Olivier
oui Jean-Paul
Jean-Paul de l'IR il quelques
instanti oui vous m'avez appelé non non
non non j'appel Robert pour lui dire que
pour lui dire que le groupe de tête se
composait de 28 hommes exactement 28
est-ce que vous pouvez justement n
donner les noms afin que ceux qui ont
besoin de connaître la course d'un bout
à l'autre tandis que N ruivons encorea
et le petit Wien winen qui a qui a
triomphé ici winen oui c'est un
spécialiste de la montée dealpest mais
aujourd'hui le maillot jaune me semble
encore beaucoup plus à l'aise que les
jours précédents ça durera ou ça ne
durera pas dece Pignot avec Cabrera sur
la droite çaaccélère petit à petit il y
a des gens qui se sentent nerveux et
Pignot n'oubliant pas qu'il est un
grimpeur espagnol catalogué parmi les
trois
premiers fait un très bon Tour d'Espagne
malheureusement il a été victime de
chute il a perdu énormément de temps
mais on ne le connaî pas très bien dans
le dans le Tour de France mais là il a
l'air de posséder toutes ses facultés et
certainement il faut s'attendre à une
performance de sa part aujourd'hui aussi
à ce
groupeisour
Zimerman s'est replacé et sans doute
assez déçu que son attaque n'est pas
réussie s'est replacé en 10e ou 12e
position mais incontestablement c'est
l'un des hommes à suivre de cette
journée dans un groupe de tête qui doit
compter 23 ou
24 oui et puis c'est un homme capable de
faire des chevauchers de 100 150 km
oublions pas une année il a fait une
poursuite derrière le H et lon ici
l'Alpe du il avait pratiquement pas
perdu même il avait un peu comblé son
retard ici lors de l'arrivée de l'Alpe
duise et aujourd'hui Zimerman a l'air
d'être en forme et c'est une montée au
train de ce colle du Glandon qui parfois
atteint des pourcentages extravagants
mais sur une route tellement amélioré
par rapport au passé que dans la
descente les coururs vont être tout
surpris avant de se précipiter vers
l'alpise de trouver une route qui
correspond presque à une autoroute que
de progrès établi félicité voilà
maintenant Jean-François Bernard qui ne
semble pourtant pas sinon cet
essoufflement au bout du rouleau Gérard
holls Gérard
holls Jean-François Bernard est 13e donc
à 3 minutes 12 et il essaie de limiter
la casse alors qu' son retard est de8
minut FO pouvezv me donner un top
j'attends de vous pouvoir vous donner un
top j'attends une indication sur le bord
de la route mais vous savez pour
l'instant nous sommes donc dans la
montagne et rien aucune indication me
permet de de vous donner un travail à
effectuer qui soit correct alors
j'attends un instant encore
c'est recevoir de manière très
satisfaisante et bien nous allons
pouvoir le faire dans quelques instants
ça va un peu mieux là oui ça va un peu
mieux pour l'instant bon Jean-François
Bernard est donc là en perdition on l'a
dit à plus de 8 minutes Gérard nous
parlait tout à l'heure d'un abandon
possible de Jean-François Bernard mal à
l'aise alors que l'allure n'est pas
rapide et qui pourrait bien rejoindre ce
soir parmi les rends des abandons
Laurent Fignon don vous le savez sans
aucun doute il n'a pas pris le REP le
départ ce matin après son calvaire
d'hier Laurent Fignon on a r B pour
l'instant je pense qu'il se récupérera
assez vite en tout cas il faut le
souhaiter pour le cyclisme français car
à 28 ans il serait tout à fait normal
que Laurent Fignon ne puisse à nouveau
apparaître parmi les meilleurs question
pour de France c'est autre chose et
aujourd'hui Jean-François Bernard l'un
des grands espoirs frç la cruelle
expérience deè journée difficile tandis
que le maillot jaune hier pas tellement
brillant mais qui avait sauvé son ma
semble facile pour l'stant
[Applaudissements]
tjours oui
jean- et
leiss vient deindre au hommes de tête
nous avons donc en tête 30 coureurs
maintenant 30 coureurs 30 coureurs à une
allure qui semble excessive pour
beaucoup mais qui en fait doit limiter
puisque personne n'est lâché qu'au
contraire on peut revenir de
l'arrière Pascal Simon en dernière
position qui s'était retourné tout à
l'heure il y a vpol aussi dans ce groupe
de
tête
Jorg müer vient de rentrer on l'a vu il
av une banane en
vitesse et puis se reprécipite en tête
les hommes de Vicentini dossard numéro 9
qui roule sur la droite de la
route et qui doit compter deux équipiers
très précieux dans ce cas et M la petite
tête plonde de Charlie m ici suivi de
Crion à ses côté
caritou la la vraie explication n'est
pas encore lancée elle a failli de
l'être dans la Madeleine pour la
première sélection sur 190 coureurs ou
presque au départ tout à coup deux
groupes se sont formés dans la descente
après le passage à neugè vers les gorges
d'Arly quelques 20 km 40 km après le
départ donné à Morzine tout à l'heure et
ça était une sélection dans ce sens
c'est-à-dire que les poids inutiles les
faitblards comme on les Appell avec
beaucoup de respect quand même
disparaissait du pleuton pour laisser 80
bons hommes ensemble expliquer sur la
fin mais maintenant il y en a plus que
30 qui peuvent vraiment espérer quelque
chose aujourd'hui et inutile de vous
préciser que le vainqueur du Tour de
France appartient à ce groupe de 30 et
n'est pas derrière actuellement non je
ne pense pas non mais je pense que les
les Gmur vont se libérer totalement dans
l'arrivée sur à l'Alpe dues car on voit
dans cette escalade du Glandon le train
n'est pas très très rapide c'est Cabrera
qui assure ce train là pour bien sûr
pour mettre Herrera dans de bonnes
conditions mais je pense
que comme les favoris de ce Tour de
France sont ici dans ce pilotau
représenté pr du classement oui et je
pense que l'explication finale aura lieu
ici l'arrivée à à l'Alpe duest avec une
surprise ou un étonnement mais je pardon
Robert je pense qu'il y a quelques
coureurs qui décrochent là en ce moment
à
l'arrière difficulté il perd une dizaine
de mètres peuvent revenir avec l'IDE de
coéquipi c'est un passage évidment
plusile oui
jean-pa oui jean-pa Omar Hernandez et
patrino jimz des CAF de Colombie ent à
leur tour dans le groupe de tête donc
cela nous fait 32 hommes en tête de la
course et 32 dont on peut admettre que
les 20 meilleurs grimpeurs de la course
sont là
alcalaa Alcala c'est un nom qui vient
immédiatement par est toujours par les
pr une fois
encore
quiéaî hier ilétait déjà montr à son
avantage et aujourd'hui il a t il un
coup de force dans le la madele N pas
réussi mais faire confi pour la fin de
cette
éoup coup toujours en 3
position
voilà ce grand gaillard un
norvégienqu difficultés à suivre le
train est-ce qu'il souffre d'une
blessure puisil est tombé dans la
descente après avoir franchi le sommet
de la mal en prière
position toujours pas de top écoute je n
absolument aucune indication qui puiss
per de
travaentcun essayer d'improviser j'avais
bien un petit Vél moteur sur la gauche
mais vous savez il était alors attention
alors à la borne attention top
top la borne numéro 927 borne numéro
927 numéro 927 bien reçu Gérard oui bien
reçu Jean-Paul et je vous signale
entreetemps que le petit groupe de
Jean-François Bernard c'est-à-dire en
fait le leader de la formation Toshiba
accompagné par lu et André
a réussi à recoller un Ploton d'une
disons de 40 unités dans lequel il y a
Thierry Marie il y a le Belge Morgan il
y a qui d'autre encore hernandz
également ce qui fait que ce sera
sansoute un petit peu moins difficile
pour le le leader donc jean-fançois
Bernard le leader de Toshiba donc bne
927 bien reçu mais ça active maintenant
jor mer le Suiss accéléré brutalement
Cabrera c'est aussit précipité dans son
sillage et du même coup le pleuton de
ces hommes de tête 32 unités en tout
c'est considérablement étiré il y en a à
qui ça fait mal cette accélération de
Jorg Müller qui venait à peine de
rejoindre le pleoton on l'a vu en direct
avaler rapidement une
banane Cabrera sait plus trop quoi faire
maintenant il se retourne pour savoir si
Herrera est là mais il y a également
Para Para qui depuis hier est devenu un
rival national pour in et la soirée et
la nuit à Bogota s passé évidemment sur
un air de fête ça ne va pas parce que
c'était le 14 juillet rien à voir à
Bogota et à Paris mais à chacun sa
manière de fêter le Jour national la
victoire de Para transformé tout le
monde Kelly qui serait revenu non non
c'est pas le group c'estutre Pleon ça
c'est le deuxè Pleon bah il limite il
limite la casse là pour l'instant il est
enompagnie d'hommes qui ne demande pas à
prendre les relais et don objectiflement
de terminer par
exheureoccup la
[Applaudissements]
dansoindoup
[Musique]
lesbiourvitablement présenter
enêteil s'agit d'affrter la monagne oui
alors qu'on pensait aujourd'hui avoir
une étape assez fraîche le va courir
dans bonnes condition atmosphérique mais
malgré tout assez chaud ona qu'il éer
tout le monde au en accélérant tout à
l'heure il a un petit passage pour
laisser cabr déborder sur la gauche mais
suivi deis ici là
encore c'est le du tour de France des
coureurs qui apportent quelque chose de
tout à fait nouveau sur la course dans
le oui sur prend très
agréablement je pense que ce soir
certains vont faire un B considérable
classement général vont réapparaître au
prière
placeir un courur important déjàit
ao de plus en plus difficile les
derniers kilomètres du Glandon sur une
route rendement pas sûr il change
beaucoup
par cont la des
[Musique]
magnif
à vous
Jean-Paul VI de perdre le contact avec
le groupe
pas pas qui VI de faire
cont ah qui
revient ça c'est curieux zob qui revient
avec beaucoup plus de facilité est-ce
que Pascal commence à coincer
aussi lui en voudrait pas parce que il
n'est pas le premier
ou alors ils sont ravitaill peuttre le
voiture direct
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
spétion don son équipier français r le
des plus Brant
aujourd'hui per de
longur dans le
de
Jérôme Simon
[Musique]
important pour lui parce que il pouvait
aujourd'hui espérer endosser le maillot
jaune et le voilà maintenant contraint à
mener la poursuite puisqu'il occupe la
deè place à 11 secondes de
ber tout le monde va le
laisser réaliser la
poursuite difficile pour les autres de
faire autrement c'est la loi impitoyable
Steven Haen dans son sillage
et Jérôme alors que son frère Pascal
appartenant à une autre équipe a réussi
à s'accrocher lui au group de
tête ça c'est le
fléchissement imparable inévitable il a
tellement donné jusquici mais n'est pas
pour autant que doiv considérer comme
définitivement perdu l'espoir pour lui
de prendre le maillot jaune oui mais
c'est difficile à rétablir la situation
lorsquon sait après la montée ici sur
l'Alpe du qui est
redoutable sur la fin de course il a
souvent chement
àu ente jusque qui vient de faire un
petit sa sur pign que les autres ont
déjà atteint la
[Musique]
Vall
[Applaudissements]
dans ce pleuton où tout le monde
s'interroge quel est le meilleur des
candidats à la victoire finale parce que
Paris approche nous sommes dans les
Alpes c'est un tour un peu plus court
des règlements
internationaux pendant 15 jours é si
rapide qu'on l'a pas vu
passer jours exactement alala
am Jean-Claude lecl le3
champion de France Résid
Suisse dispaintenant é
pour 10
km oui vousz problème de
[Musique]
micro is mais toujours parmi les
premiers par en dernière position avec
son
sur la droite de la route
alala mexicain de l'équipe
américainen est officiellement le
leader et puis une léère
portion plus det pas arche de
[Musique]
laère
[Applaudissements]
position
om pass la colonie de vacan puisque n
sont les
ENS je c'est
[Applaudissements]
groupe
trs lo
d'ailleurs des nouvelles de
Jean-François Bernard à
l'arrièreard jeçis vraiment que sur à si
nos amis de la SFP si mes copains si mes
frères P faire quelque chose sera
vraiment extraordinaire parce que
j'avouentends absolument pas ni les
questions vousz commentaire évidemment
très ferru très très pointu que vous
prononcez ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que maintenant jeanfançois Bernard est
bien entouré puisqu'il a autour de lui
quatre équipiers au moins dont je vous
le disais tout à l'heure la merers et le
leu qui roule en compagnie en
particulier de du CL la S sal de Thierry
Marie c'est un groupe donc d'une
quarantaine
d'hommes qui est quand même loin loin
loin par rapport au top de Jean-Paul
Olivier tout à l'heure sur les 10 km je
vous rappellerai que nous passerons la
bandrôle de 10 km tandis que Ronal
pinceek a été aperçu rapidement vient
d'être victime d'un accident mécanique
alors qu'il avait réintégré le groupe de
tête
Abad il est maudit aujourd'hui
Abad alors à quelques minutes de là un
autre groupe avec Pedersen jorggen
Pedersen pas tout à fait à son aise sur
ce Tour de France
d'ailleurs avec
laosen on est entre scandinav dans ce
groupe mais l'essentiel pour ces gens
c'est de ne pas perdre plus de 2 3
minutes et d'espérer revenir dans la
descente ce qui n' absolument rien
d'impossible c'est d'attendre des jours
meilleurs et surtout des étapes beaucoup
plus favorables
pour surprise de retrouver quand même là
en
têteouping ouiing l'un des favoris Qui
conait peut-être les les mêmes ennuis
que jean-fançois Bernard et qui a été
donné sans doute sur recommandation de
son directeur sportif alors qu'il porte
le maillot blanc et est placé en 3e
position au classement général à 43
secondes d'un groupe qui doit le
précéder d'au moins au moins 3 minutes
un autre favori qui va peut-être
disparaître ce soir ah oui élimination
quotidienne ce que nous avions
prévu qui arrive brutalement pour
certains à l'avant ici personne ne prend
initiative de démarrer ce qui permet à
Abad une nouvelle fois de recoller au
groupe de tête il éé le courur accordéon
aujourd'hui et broking qui monte à son
train va récupérer trois hommes
abandonnés eux aussi par le groupe de
tête il les passe et il a bien raison
parce qu'il ne faut pas perdre trop de
temps Sanchez a été sorti mais qui était
échappé tout à l'heure et était lui
aussi qui était
devant non mais il étaitê du ahbe par
sé vous l'zans doute à l'image vousavez
pasce etad donc tente de recoller alors
que Pascal figure dans les dernièr
position du groupe
deêteun group à l'autre nous nous
remontons en attendant la présence de
l'hélicoptère et c'est instantané bravo
oui ou je suis en compag
de Paul Paul vous êtes émerveillé de
l'attitude de Steve ber votre maillot
jaune oui bien sûr mais pour le moment
il y a plus que 30 coureurs en tête donc
il est clair qu'il est un bon coureur
mais une fois que les choses sérieuses
vont commenc je pense qu'il va quand
même avoir quelques difficulté pour
suivre les meilleur spécialist merci ça
c'est bien l'humour de Paul cour Suisse
quand les choses sérieuses vont
commencer si vous demandez à ceux qui
roulent 10 minutes 15 minutes 30 minutes
ce groupe de tête que le dit que les
choses sérieuses n'ont pas encore
commencé serait surpris Denou tout à
fait à son aise en danseuse au
milieu l'allure s accélérée oui oui les
hommes de Delgado qui
comm gr alors que le ryth effec
s'accélère toujours l'ascension du
Glandon une des difficultés majeures de
la journée sinon la plus difficile étant
donné qu'elle était placée qu'elle est
placée tout de suite à la sortie du col
de la Madeleine après la descente vers
la chambre et la montée du Glandon dont
le kilométrage n'est pas officiellement
indiqué en bas mais Don on sait que se
résume en une bonne trentaine de
kilomètresichich il a la descente pour
lui mais encore faut-il se pointer
là-haut pas tellement loin des tout
premiers pour reprendre deux ou 3
minutes est capable de
faire les voitures sont là à 50 m ce
n'est pas qu'en montagne ça soit un
avantage surtout que on se retrouve dans
les vapeurs dans conditions de
nuisance difficile à soutenir et Delgado
Delgado tout à fait à son aise dans le
signage de Omar
Hernandez l'un de ses meilleurs
partenaires si pvait dire à l'instant
même
par
[Musique]
Desages on pit direant même quel est le
meilleur Delgado Hera ou alala puis ce
sont les
hommes plus
grosvant pas c'estàd au soir au soir de
de l'étape de hier hier on aurait pu
dire que Delgado a passé peut-être
devant Herrera au point de vue favori il
est peut-être beaucoup plus citer kerera
mais ce soir oui répondra peut-être plus
facilement à cette question pour pour
l'instant c'est pratiquement
impossible un écrmage commence avec
Pascal Simon lâché PCE
lâché
lâchéad que nous suivons Abad lâché
aussi oui mais c'est là là quelle
impression quelle impression terrible
une moto qui passe à côté de vous et
vous laisse sur place he Robert il il
semble également que crickon a quelques
difficulté à suivre le train Claudie
crickellon et rutyan également et tout
ça sur l'accélération de Omar hernandz à
la demande de son chef de fil le
delgadout herandz toujours en première
position Delgado en 2e peut-être
s'est-il aperçu de passage à vide de
herera il n'est pas impossible également
puis qu'on ne le voit pas aux
avant-postes pour l'instant
al
pascandon son chef de F
char
Grou qui doit laisser du même coup se
débrouiller tout
seul et puis
[Musique]
d'autes quial
défble- oh là oh il y a beaucoup de
numéro 1 qui tomb c'estàd les leader le
numéro 9 c'esteni jusque là il laiss
beaucoup d'espoir nos confrères de la
presse
italienne dis que le Tour de
France
il est habitué à un meilleur régime mais
là justement sur la première montagne il
coince alors clavolin don on avait
admiré le retour tout à l'heure suivi
d'uneaque à son tour sur une route don
le
rendement je pas impraticable on sent la
différence lque les sons
comm
devent
oui oui gér la moto oui je suis
à Colomban des Villards sa Colomban des
Villards c'està-dire à 10 km du sommet
du Glandon et Jean-François Bernard
accuse maintenant un retard de 10
minutes et 20 secondes 6 minutes et 20
secondes sur le groupe de tête ouais lui
aussi donc c'est ce que c'est que de
souffrir en ce moment et on l'encourage
mais tout est définitivement perdu pour
le Tour
Hernandez pardon il est très très mal
parce que il est en il est en queue
maintenant du groupe il ferme la c'est
lui pratiquement qui ferme la marche du
groupe de 40 coureurs qui ét à plus de
10 minutes des leaders et il Doig
gambberger en sachant très bien que
après tout cela il va falloir monter
l'alpeedise et autant qu'il n'y pense
pas
tropementz
leombien Hernandez qui impose un tra
très sévère c'est pruve que Delgado doit
se sentir très très à sinon il lui
aurait demandé depuis très longtemps de
d'arrêter un peu ARYO ici oui oui
Jean-P chacun a droit
alorsimz et AR ça pas n'importe qui
pourtant en montagne alors attendonsnous
à retrouver selon l'indication de
jean-pa Olivier en dernière position de
ce groupe Charlie
m est en train d'être lâché c'est qui
est en train d'être lâché maintenant en
compagnie de et moté se trou toujours
dans le paquet c'est bon c'est power
maintenant qui VI d'être lâché non non
il il est resté en contact avec tout le
monde le voici BO et c'est oui le voici
donc Ramirez qui est avec lui Martine
Ramirez Colombie m é dans la dernière
position mais il a maintenu le contact
donc il pour relâcher oui cette sois
mais Jérôme Simon le plus dangereux pour
Boer au classement général et broking
l'autre dangereux étant très nettement
derrière lui plus de 3 minutes donc ber
s'il franchit convenablement le Glandon
peu dans la descente mais au prix de
risque qu'il faut prendre quand on veut
espérer terminer parmi les tout premiers
du Tour de France ber dans la descente
peut peut-être récupérer quelques
coureurs et finalement dans la très
courte portion de plaine avant
l'incension de l'alpest reprendre sa
place en tête mais là maintenant la
parole est vraiment au grimpeur pour la
première fois les 10 qui sont là réunis
sont sans aucun doute les 10 meilleurs
montagners
ah oui certainement et puis on voit que
le train qu'impose Hernandez pour son
leader Delgado est très très rapide
c'est pour cette raison que les coureurs
qui ne sont pas très bien décrochent et
certainement il il va en décrocher
d'autres que Gard reçit et bien je viens
de passer à côté d'une vend club Laurent
Fignon top top pour les hommes de tête
oui des supporters qui doivent être
déçus de ne pas voir passer Laurent mais
qui sont ven que la grande band tandis
que car tout à son tour le champion de
France remarquable escaladeur et suit sa
petite défaillance peut-être lourde mais
encore une fois sont des défaillances
souvent
passagres c'est fou je vous disais tout
à l'heure ils sont fousman il attaqu il
heure il é extrêmement brillant et là il
navigue complètement sur la route là
c'est le gros coup de bar pour ah
ouiou 10 m de la ba ça fa un beau trio S
se reconstituit mais dans quel état
voilà qui arrive avec Martine
Ramirez le
colombien a du
mal on dit qu'un grand champion con les
plus grandes défaillances qu'il est en
de connaître RA en tout cas qu'il est un
grand
champion tout le monde a mis l'accent
sur l'intelligence de course de
Delgado qu'il a d s'apercevoir que soit
Zimerman soit Hera nétait peut-être pas
dans un bon jour c'est pour cette raison
qu'il a fait accélérer son équipier
d'ailles c'est ce qui se passe ça fait
du dégât on peut ti lagado ench à chacun
son jour
c'est nous voyons
àéc vingtaine de MTR est Lavi et
derrière c'est Ramirez
quientage sont beaucoup bien par
toujours en
tête de la course en prière position
Omar
hernandz qui vaut mieux que d'être unid
dans formation Ry Delgado est d'ffirmer
la
présenceem pas
[Musique]
forcmentverâ
est
[Musique]
ementainjeespagoup
gr avec beaucoup de difficult mais il
son environ à 300 m groupe deête
maintenant qui vient se porter parmi les
premiers maisard nous appelle à
l'arrière ouier juste peutêtre pour une
suggestion je sais pas si est
bneerit pas bon que la deè camé vidéo
vious rejoindre sur jean-fç Berard par
il est vraiment difficulté il est nelle
FO lâchéèement du groupe deête bien
caméi plus de 10 minutes ver chrreistr
sur Leard jeis Berard ve
[Musique]
enc et comme va maintenant que l'on
retrouve ici en compagnie de ARYO
toujours ARYO qui fut un remarquable
montagnard et qui est quand même parmi
les 20 meilleurs montagnard du monde
dans cette situation dans cette position
là tis n produit une grosse impression
ce maillot blanc que l'on voit ici
représentant la formation PDM qui tout à
l'heure pouvait encore compter à ses
côtés rox et vanerpou assez brutalement
disparu tandis que la petite frimousse
de Charlie mot se rapproche de
l'arrière Hernandez qui semble accélérer
alal on
termineis ne se laisse pas faire
remonter d'Alcala sur un petit démarrage
dont il a le secret tout à fait
commea et om Hernandez a tellement de
puissance en lui que sur un léger faux
plat au moment en tout cas où P est
beaucoup moins accentué c'est ravitaill
etour et Chav également ah c'est le
massacre c'est la journé massacre c'est
un 14 juillet plein de
pétard et nous
voicicl signal la présence tout à
l'heure mais lui aussi est doté d'un
démarrage qui lui permet parfois de
reprendre quelques mètres et on n pas
l'impression à le voir que lâcher
régulièrement avoir un petit mécanique
cherch à faire appel à son directeur
SP encore un bon
[Applaudissements]
et tous ne reviendront pas dans la
descud vraiment un ralentissement des
hommes de tête récupérant quelque
peu pour affronter l' avec
[Musique]
l'arrivé car la descente je pense que
Delgado va la prendre comp c'est un
excellent car des fantastique accompli
dans les pyrénés Cabrera c'est lui qui a
donné le temps tout à l'heure si vous
voulez l'auteur du M qui a condamné
Jean-François Bernard et
d'autresell c'est cabrer par cette
accélération brutale derrière lecl et AB
sur la montée du de la nabline il VI a
de cela 1 HEC mtenant et il fait à son
sa généros mais il un pouvoir une
faculté de récupération en montagne les
Colombiens surtout que nous approchons
des 2000 m que parfois ils effuent des
retour sensationnel ah oui ils sont
habitués à ce genre
[Applaudissements]
d'exercice toujours les mêmes en
tête de pas
mieuxo c'est sacrié comme ça en tê ah
oui mais je crois que c'est il peut-être
considéré dès à présent comme une des
révélations de ce
révélation jours en montagne au même
ticume oui ce matin
je une conversation qui m'a étonné d'un
journalistequ a posé les question il est
bien ce Tour de France jusqu'ici moyen
ah bon regard je pense pas que j'avis
converser
avec non je crois qu'il va être fabuleux
et aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
vivre une étape mémorable ici comme il y
en a tous les ans lors de l'arrivée de
l'Alpe
oui mais ce n'est pas un fait
exceptionnel donc vous venez de
souligner mais depuis 10 jours c'est à
croire que personne ne pensait à la
montagne à l'alpise en particulier et a
d'autres montagnes qui nous attendent
dès demain avec enchaînement direct sur
les pyéné parce que un tour de France a
compris à 42 km de moyenne jusqu'ici on
peut pas faire mieux hein oui mais ce
qu'il faut noter je crois que l'étape a
été vraiment pris à bras de corp par les
grimpeurs qui n'ont laissé aucune
échappée se développer je crois que
c'est un fait nouveau qu'il faut
signaler alors que para là lève le
bras il lève le bras il lève aussi le
pied un peu hein ah oui est-ce que il a
dû se passer quelque chose là
comprendable pourquoi parain ne chercha
pas à récupérer une place parmi les
premers alors que Guimar se porte à la
hauteur des hommes échappé maintenant de
ces hommes et que plusieurs d'entre eux
réclament un ravitaillement en eau
fraîche
ouais comprend un peu réclamer
[Musique]
àure
et que les de
colombiens donc l'espagnol entre
deombiab il faut signaler la présence de
[Musique]
éalement maais res tout à l'HE
il avait eu t de s'y confiner mais ce
que je vous annoncais à propos des
Colombiens il est récupéré
Gérard Robert
oui une petite information venant de
l'arrière l'abandon de l'espagnol anelm
fuer et une nouvelle fois une nouvelle
fois Jean-François Bernard en difficulté
le le drame continue à chaque fois qu'il
y a un coup de Rin à donné à chaque fois
que le pourcentage de ce col du Glandon
est augmente et bien jean-fançois
Bernard est lâché il ne reste plus avec
lui que Philippe l et la MERER voilà il
est justement il est juste accompagné
par deux équipiers et il est pour
l'instant à la dérive et ce 14 juillet
c'est aussi la fête pour certains des
leaders désignés comme tel avec le
dossard numéro 1 respectivement dans sa
formation donc dans leur formation et
fouerté c'était encore un homme dont le
passé tellement brillant incité à croire
les
PUL
ser
attends des nouvelles de Zimerman à
l'arrière plus minutes naue
littéralement il a mal du mal du mal
àevenir je est-ce qu'on peut rappeler
les noms des coururs figurant dans ce
groupe de tête limité à une quzain
peut-être 17 au
maximum je
vas mais n pas fa mainten puisque je
suis unetite
re passage des directeurs sportifs
s'impose bien sûr en
priorité nous sommes sur la toute petite
route que vous avez franchi tout à
l'heure et nous sommes là à côté
deschavés nous avons définitivement
lâcher donc Zimerman qui prouvait un
certain nombre de difficultés à suivre
le TR je regarde dans les lacet derrière
j'aperçois Crick et Lyon mais je n
pererçois plus du tout Zimerman com il
se trouve dans groupe de tête
apparemment oui apparemment mais pour
l'instant il vient de se faire lâcher il
est à 30 m environ yanouscum tandis
que Pignot reprend la première place
mais au rchigne à mener le vent souffle
un peu au
sommet et deirou revient de l'arrière
pour faire la première place voulait
démarrer mais s troué dans le
gazon Jean-François Bernard
[Musique]
nelland je viensinroger le docteur le
médecin du Tour de France alors ce qui s
passé en fait c'est que il craint le
docteur por que il y ait une inction ce
serait pas tout à fait pubalie pas
toutit d'origine musculaire sera plôt
une inction il a des ganglons dans l'
ils ont faitir une analyse pour savoir
ce que c'était il n pas encore les
résultats mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il est à bout de force le médecin du
Tour de France vient de me le confirmer
et une nouvelle fois il est lâché là ça
y est il y a il y a un trou qui est fait
avec la quarantaine de coureurs donc qui
forment une sorte de deuxième peloton
derrière c'est-à-dire Finet bonis
Gonzalez bruyère vanerarden Thierry
Marie capess Duclos la sal le bob roll
l'Américain Da Silva Dominique Gard
grégis clair aussi ils ont beaucoup de
mal beaucoup de mal puisqu'ils sont
maintenant à plus de 11 pratiquement 12
minutes
je Bernard qui
zigzag encore un autre en difficulté
ilétait déjà tout à l'heure Martin
Ramirez t dit il nous faut rappeler que
Jérôme
Simon cou jusqu 12 km du sommeton avec
son maillot deer de la montagne il est
aussi leader maillot performance mais
comme il peut pas porter quand même de
maillot à la fois maillot de performance
estorté par r don on parle depuis le
début
detion le Hollandais
chef de F de
PDN Ramirez qui semble en
difficulté à son tour Boyer jean-pa vous
dites oui oui je vais essayer de
m'approcher davantage avec Daniel motard
mais il est très très difficile ici de
de
s'approcher auprès des voiture d' près
des voitures même car il y a une
priorité absolue au directeur sportif
bien s je on s'aperçoit donc
effectivement juste là devant moi avec
para avec moté avec herera avec Amstein
avec tenis avec rox avec Denis rou bien
sûr avec winen avec alkala avec Delgado
bien entendu avec Renan pinsek al voilà
je crois que je vous ai donné à peu près
tous les noms qui composent ce groupe
et je vais tenter d'en faire la
comptabilité il y a en tête
12 très précisément au moment
oùoccupe la place est de décrocher
[Applaudissements]
àentreage comm le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faitèrep maintient la première place et
qui a dû apprendre
maintenant que son chef de fil
fuerté était lui aussi en grosse
difficulté voilà je crois que vous avez
les 12 rever avec pign que je ne vous ai
pas signalé le voici Pignot en première
position tenis qui à son tour arrache un
peu n'est plus aussi facile que tout à
l'heure alors qu'il faut tout de même
signaler quand même le très gros travail
de Denis rou pendant toute cette montée
et qui se trouve maintenant en compagnie
de ronand Passek dans son C
magnifique oui il est là
deè il reste un peu à l'image de ce
qu'il avait été l'année dernière dans
l'école c'est-à-dire qu'il avait
accompagné les meilleurs on a vu moté
pins également qui compose ce groupe de
12 Ah herera en difficulté pour il
réclame à boire il réclame à boire oui
il n'est pas forcément en difficulté
mais oh c'est mauvais signe oui oui oui
ou c'est effectivement mauvais signe
mais il reste à quelques mètres ça y est
il rentre dans la route Wien maintenant
comme vous l'avez et Alcala est en
devant Wien devant lui c'est pas avec
facilité que revient sur le sur le
groupe prend un peu de vent aussi et
Delgado qui doit le savoir à démarrer
Delgado s'en va
seul ah décision nette au bénéfice de
Delgado mais on a déjà vu ça dans le
passé puira revenir sur lui et Delgado à
son tour frir ça c'est un combat au
sommet c'est le cas de le
dire Delgado devant r
oh cette accération de plus en plus àiv
ou ce que N
av manière de prendre la bouteille d'eau
minéraleend par un spectateur à 1 kmgado
et eng à faire une descente TER pour
éviter le retour il n pas joué uniement
le passage en prière position
accélération nelle
fois
par a tellement de place ave vioir dans
les CL avait oublié était donccr parmi
les plus
[Applaudissements]
dangereuxén
maetour des de la manière qu'il a
[Musique]
comblite x ah oui il a fait une course
très sage à l'arrière en récupérant de
ses efforts d'hier mais estil capable
justement de jours de
suite de s'afficher au premier plan dans
la montagne 250 m qui revient très très
fort ensuite suivi d'Alvaro P d'AM de de
tenis de M de R et à tout petit peu plus
loin à quelques mètres se trouve Wien et
herera qui a toujours beaucoup de
difficultés à suivre et qui vient son
tour d'être lâché
on attendait un peu mieux sur le dernier
kilomère surtout mais comme on le Pass à
égalité avec Hera il le seront mais dans
la difficulté et pas la prière place de
la manière que R a comblé l'écart et
répu au démarrage de Delgado en D sur
formeten 7
MP ant très réduit Delgado qui
continue qui court pour la gagne non
seulement de l'étape encore une fois
passer en tête du Glandon ça marque
c'est impressionnant et surtout ça
impressionne les adversaires mais avec R
brutalement la situation a changé pour
lui oui bien sûr et comme j'ai dit tout
à l'heure Delgado a dû s'apercevoir que
Herrera n'était pas bien aujourd'hui
c'est pour cette raison qu'il a fait
monter son équipier hernandz tout le col
du du Glandon et très rapidement voyz au
charbon et il a parfaitement réussi son
son travail aussi Hernandez tout comme
Martinez Oliver hier avait fait le
travail pour para avant la dernière
ascension lancer mettre sur orbite son
grimpeur et puis c'est à lui de se
débrouiller là-haut
ensuitea est lâché à son tour Herrera
est lâché à son tour par alkala qui va
revenir dans le groupe de tête ah oui
donc tout seul derrière et personne
n'est épargné à part R et Delgado tout
le monde et tenis compris tout le monde
a pris son petit coup de de tric
et c'est à celui qu'il connaîtra le
moins longtemps possible
[Applaudissements]
Alcala que sa manière de faire
d'ailleurs récupérera sa place même dans
la descente il est tellement complet se
promène littéralement a ah à côté de
Delgado qui est pourtant au sommet je le
répète Delgado ça n'est un mystère pour
personne veut gagner le Tour de France
il était
va peut-tre combl son
retard avant juste
avant temp
dans la manière desombi reviend quianch
le prier la lig somandon devant Delgado
dans son sillage le chron défile
derrière pour connaître le retard sur
leè et rou tout comme Delgado au passage
a saisi un 3e para à 23 secondes a saisi
un journal le plus épais possible pour
le visser sous son maillot et avec le
maillot retour herera retour dans le
groupe de tête juste 60 m avant le
sommetry r moté on a vu aussi 6e
position 7e
position maintenant reste à savoir pe
près de partout à la fois ce que sont
dus Jérôme Simon et je pense que cette
caméra au sommet va nous permettre avec
Jean-René Vivet de nous faire une idée
sur la question que sont devenus Jérôme
Simon breing
vizentini Crick lon poum et wiinen qui
occupait les places au classement
général ce matin au départ derrière Baer
c'est Cabrera qui doit passer
maintenanton é environ 10 et Zimerman à
plus de 3 minutes ber et son maillot
jaune une minute 17 ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Boy et les minutes vont défiler
maintenant en attendant peut-être qu'
renonce avant jean-fançois Bernard aux
alentour de 12 13 minutes
mais on sait pas du tout ce qu'il va
décider puisquil est le patron de son
équipe à son
tour dans la
douleur dans la
douleur à peu près en 25e position d'un
groupe qui a éclaté après avoir
ééir réuni 32 coureurs sur l'ascension
du blandon à 10 km du
som
[Applaudissements]
es précaution ce reportage nous allons
le poursuivre jusqu jusau passage de
jean-fançis Bernard et puis si vous n
permettez Pouru les ravitaills
nécessaires et surtux des hélicoptères
qui ont priorité enoccasion nous nous
rendrons à Paris pendant quelques
minutes etrouverons pour l'arrivée à
l'Alpe d' toute l'ascension depuis
Bourdois et les
dans la station habit le Tour de France
habit àan le Tour de France
àir
[Applaudissements]
leur
minut Clement
génér le chrono 3 minutes
[Applaudissements]
18 arrive vers le sommet on é chercher
très
loin pas non plus ceon attend deioin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deiouphi ser s doute le Meille desende
plus plusitter maintenant lequel peut
réussir à conserver que suivant immédiat
carrément cqué peut espér conserver
[Applaudissements]
son
différam
c pas qu'il faudra lui demander de fois
envie
d'abandonner la chance de VI
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
heureuxre
ADM peutre
pe encore un
groupe
4 5 cétait celui qu'occupait tout à
l'heure jean-fançois Bernard
maising en
revanche
[Applaudissements]
gr voici jérô Simon avec un retard de 5
minutes 10 second allez mon gars une
bonne des on sait Jama en coupe s on
peut revenir mais lui aussi a
flanché au moment où il jouait tout une
nouvelle fois espérant enfin arracher
son maillot jaune van derpou qui a fait
une bonne
[Applaudissements]
montée envie du crier à
fist près de 6 minutes
maintenant éé franchi par r devant Bel
à une longueur et le Ploton avec un
retard ramené maintenant une vingtaine
de secondes dans la descente Ro et
Delgado peuvent peuvent doivent même
continuer jusqu'au
bouterpol passé le sommet à 6 minutes
juste ce soir que dans votre
conversation familiale et quotidienne
vous lui rappellerez son
passage lui aussi se le rappellera
ce je pense que lui également va
disparaître de la liste des
l'impressionnante liste de favoris ce
Tour de France ou mais c'est aussi
tellement Morali tellement mental
que sa pas trop
[Applaudissements]
B les écarts considérablement on a d
voir passer au maximum 45 à 50
coureurs
est
pass justement devant lui son
coéipierp il doiv savoir que c'est
quianch
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
position Gerard vous grimpez toujours en
compagnie de Jean-François
Bernard
Gard jean-pa
Olivier je pense que dans la descente
pour eux c'est difficile de PIR répondre
littéralement à pied derni m
de quelle
désillusion comme il doit être
malheureux qui ce matin parce que autour
de lui on répétait mais tu peux gagner
le Tour de France microer il a quand
même le réflexe de prendre lui aussi son
journal ce n'est pas pour la lecture
mais c'est simplement pour se préserver
des coups de vent dans la descente et
surtout des suites car le lendemain
matin si on a pris frais sur le
ventre les intestins vous le rappellent
oui et puis cette descente il est je
pense pas que ça revienne de l'arrière
puisque Delgado va faire cette descente
car il est en train de peut-être de
gagner le Tour de France ici alors comme
c'est un très bon descendeur les 50
prers sont beaucoup trop éparpillés pour
respérer autre que des regroupements
partiels mais pas un regroupement quoisi
général pour aborder la montée de l'Alpe
d'ouise ce qui s'est déjà vu dans le
passé mais enfin ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui ce ne sera pas le
cas
retrouve
[Applaudissements]
madio notre caméra qui nous permet de
suivre la fin de l'ascension de madio
sur le Glandon à 9 minutes environ du
premier des deux premiers Ro et
[Applaudissements]
Delgado un pleuton plus important là ou
toujours pas de Jean-François Bernard
son équipier qui nétait pourant pas loin
[Applaudissements]
devanting plus expour
deance
[Applaudissements]
tr
c'est extraordinaire cette
sélection strictement individuelle
uneton de 6 ça paraî énorme dans cette
course ah oui puis dans un col il n pas
question de de rechercher l'abri c'est
tout le monde
cont pas
[Applaudissements]
jean-fçis seulement sur la
[Musique]
ligarriv d'arrivé du
Glandon sur le
sommet non non non none la question
[Applaudissements]
gardardiper 39 ans et décidé plus jamais
terminer encore le Tour de
[Applaudissements]
France
la colonie hollandaise particulièrement
nombreuse on peut chiffrer à 50 à 0000
personnes ven de Hollande pour assister
au passage du Tour dans la nuit sur
l'école d'être d'une place et je-fançis
Bernard qui pour apparaître
maintenant
pasore
[Applaudissements]
qui est
pass que ce soit jean-fançis dans la
mesure où il était seul il est accné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de
on vraiment assisté du pied au sommet de
cette ascension du
Glandon repris jean-fçisard a été lâché
pour reprendre sa place avec beaucoup de
courage et puis tout à coup cqu pour la
dernière fois et définitivement donc sur
ce Tour de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
France je nous
devonsir plus complètement possible je
pense qu'il nous faudrait maintenant
rendre l'antenne pierre Badel afin de
permettre à tout le monde de se mettre
en place pour le deè dispositif
d'accord le champion des États-Unis
[Applaudissements]
qui ici la solidarité en des hommes loin
loin des groupes de
tête avec
voilà les derniers escaladeurs du
Glandon que nous allons regarder une
cquantaine d'hommes au moins roule
encore derrière eux dans de pires
conditions et la monter vers l'Alpe d'Es
promet promet compte tenu de ce que nous
avons vu sur le Glandon promet d'être
d'une sévérité peut-être jamais atteinte
jusquici V conion ouiement il
fautattendre des effondrements puisquon
a vu que Herrera était en difficulté
Delgado avait l'air d'être très très
bien et surtout rox qui nous a fait
impression terrible et n'oublions pas
ici il y a pratiquement les TR pas les
tr/arts mais la moitié du public
hollandais COMC que les Hollandais ont
énormément de réussite ici à l'Alpe dues
alors il faut peut-être s'attendre exp
il ils sont dans leur carré orange là
alors nous allons
retrouver parade avec Gérard
et toute cette équipe qui nous promet
une émission que nous connaissons déjà
de réputation et que nous verr tout au
long de l'année tout au long de l'été en
tout cas en les remerciant surtout
d'avoir bien accepté de donner l'antenne
au Tour de France au début de leur
émission merci à vous à tout à
[Applaudissements]
l'heure
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on reçoit
Rober si tu trouves est-ce que
oui ben c'est parfait si Robert me
reçoit également c'est parfait
oui mais Robert est làert là je suis là
là je suis là bon ok tu vas bien le
classement de à bordoisin tu vas bien
ouais ouais ça va bien FO
oui je
t'écoute j'écoute alors c'est passé
j'écoute moi j'entends mais Robert a pas
l'air d'entendre si alors j'écoute oui
de toute façon si tu m'entend oui
parfaitement euh donc R est passé en
tête devant Delgado hein
pierre Badel tu nous
entends moi je t'entends très bien oui
Rob Robert oui ouient pas lui je je
voulais donner à Robert un dernier écart
à 15 km de l'arrivée c'està-dire en bas
oui 1 minute 07 secondes ah d'accord
alors que au j'entends pas Robert alors
alors qu'au cat bonification ro est
passé en tête devant Delgado d'accord tu
sais que ça y est ils ont commencé
l'ascension là ça y est je suis avec eux
là d'accord je me laisse glisser je
laisse glisser vers le le je pas Robert
d'accord parce que j'aimerais bien
savoir si si on entend Gérard
Gérard saard é très très loin derrière
bon est-ce qu'on a des nouvelles de
Bernard à combien navigue-til au moment
où il navigue à plus de 16 minutes plus
de 16 minutes ouais il abandonne pas
hein B pour l'instant on a pas encore
son euh je vais peut-être qu'il y a un
écart plus récent hein on va demander à
PIR là attends bouge pas j'entends
j'entends si ends c'est bien alors oui
attend il fait pas chaud ici hein non
couvre-toi mon petit poulet il fait pas
chaud ici Jérôme Simon est à 8 minutes
presque oh là là combien il est passé
Bernard ils sont dans la montée là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
man merci alors Jérôme Simon 7 minutes
20 est-ce que vous me recevez toujours
oui tu vas le dire ouais d'accord 7
minutes 20 Etman 11 minutes 7 minutes
d'accord on se met derrière hein
Daniel on les laisse passer on se met
derrière ça va être difficile à réaliser
pour Badel
[Musique]
ou
Alcala en train de décrocher
[Applaudissements]
là on a on a eu des problèmes de son he
tout à l'heure oh là là terrible
impouventable terrible alors là je suis
sûr qu'on s'est chevauché mais je je
suis vraiment pas responsable non ben
non personne n responsable un C fouillli
moment Gérard on entendait très mal et
moi j'arrêtais ici de parler pour
cas où une de vos informations passait
tu comprends à la limite c'était la
meilleure chose parce que on s'entendait
pas alors mais moi je te donnais que des
infos importantes quand même quoi j'évit
de te donner des conneries quand même
c'est bien pour nous là on a à l'écran
les deux deux
têtes Alcala vient de décrocher oh là a
des ennuis la nuit de derriilleur mais
il av disparu complètement sur la
droite dans 5 minutes c'est ça il à 20 à
20 minutes
ok Rook me paraît beaucoup plus fort que
que Delgado c'est peut-être paril il a
l'air d'accuser il a plus grand aussi
hein il éit cost il éit costaud dans la
descente je suis sûr qu'il va le lâcher
c'est possible je vois son coup de pénal
il est pas herera est revenu dans la
descente hein ou là et mais il crêe
plus il roule très bien sur le plat il
est devenu un bon descendeur
ça se trouve il va les flinguer là ah
c'est pas
impossible en temps normal une minute
pour c'est rien virage 21 virage 21 rou
c'est la balade pour le
poursuivant pour les poursuivants ou ou
virage 21 ou 21 parce que ils l'ont
passé il y a quelques temps d'accord ok
mais moi je reste avec les PO suivant
derrière
[Musique]
on aurait dû rendre plutôt tout à
l'heure pour commencer ça vraiment pied
de erreur de rester trop longtemps en
haut oui ça servait à
rien
bon on va pas tarder à
décrocher herreraer
ouais mais il monte à son allure
[Musique]
aussi oh là là mé attention hein moté
pas bien ah
ouis mais foi avec Boyé hein un vu de
loin tu peux les confondre non non là je
les confonds pas du tout parce que vous
voyez déjà
larguer ça simplifie
tout Simon n'est pas revenu non plus
dans ce groupe
non mé est tout seul M tout
çaul on va qu'ils sont quelques-uns et
tout
seul
se retrouver ce soir parmi dès qu'on
prendra l'entête ça va devenir
intéressant oui mais ça sera presque le
haut non non non dans 2
minutes commence pas commence
pas pas passé le virage 20
non je vais pas
tarder en fait nous on se régale toi tu
es avec le groupe ù tu es entre les deux
ah je suis derrière le groupe et donc je
vois qui décroche voilà
virage la puissance du coup
pied terrible
[Musique]
terrible
VO
cavola cavola est
qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
é peuttre avec une auto il y a
une par jour gag des milli
d'ut
[Musique]
du
bruit à nouveau sur la route vers
l'alpdise de cette 12e étape du Tour de
France et toujours avec les deux hommes
que nous avons quitté tout à l'heure
franchissant le sommet du Glandon
ensemble Rook vainqueur de Delgado qui
avait provoqué la grande décision
derrière c'est la débandale ils avaient
30 secondes d'avance au moment où nous
les avons quitté au sommet du Glandon
pour sa part Jean-François Bernard
naviguit à plus de 16 minutes des
leaders et dans la montée de l'Alpe d'Es
vers l'Alpe d'est au fameux 16e ou 15e
virage c'est ce que nous allons
découvrir ensemble toujours Delgado
herou avec une minute d'avance sur un
pleoton d'une douzaine d'unités mais qui
il laisse des plumes en cours de route
Jean-Paul Olivier absolument Robert
effectivement donc les deux hommes sont
en tête à 58 secondes se trouvent trois
hommes Alvaro P tenis et Amstein alors
que nous allons nous laisser encore
glisser voilà donc les deux puis trois
hommes ensuite nous avons à quelques
secondes derrière pain sec et para en
compagnie
de en compagnie de
Cabrera compag de Herrera Herrera pain
sec par donc passe quelques secondes
derrière les trois premiers Denis rou
Denis rou quelques mètres derrière alors
que alors qu'à 20 secondes arrive 20
secondes de ce groupe arrive le maillot
jaune tout seul le maillot jaune Steve
Bauer et un petit peu plus loin je me
retourne nous avons winen et claverola
et encore plus loin et bien se trouve
Charlie moté Charlie moté qui se
trouvait en compagnie de Boer de
claverola et qui vient de se faire
lâcher et plus loin encore se trouve AR
Alcala et Bo voilà cétait le groupe donc
qui sétait reconstitué et qui attaqu
dans cet ordre en donc group le l'Alpe
et maintenant tout est en train de
diserert vous Jérôme Simon éta pointé
tout à l'heure à plus de 8 minutes au
sonnet du Glandon on aperçoit et pin ce
que vient de nous désigner Jean-Paul
avec un herera apparemment un peu plus
nerveux tout à l'heure mais avec lui on
ne sait jamais il est capable de telle
différence et C pins qui pour le moment
supporte toute la gloire nationale en ce
14 juillet puisque vous le savez
Jean-François Bernard est à la dérive à
l'arrière et que Jérôme Simon a perdu
plus de 8 minutes portant toujours le
maillot du meilleur grimpeur et après
avoir flé longtemps avec le maillot
jaune mais ber avait bien résisté alors
tout tient dans ce C réaction de lis
Herra avec et pin capable rejoindre
Delgado et R manifestement les deux
meilleurs sur l'ensemble de la journée
alors qu'à l'arrière je vous le répète
quand on est en 50e position on occupe
déjà une place parmi à plus de 10
minutes c'est vous dire les différences
établies sur cette étape de col à 10 km
exactement de la montée vers l'alpenaise
les deux vainqueurs les voici pour
l'instant les deux vainqueurs du Glandon
en tout cas avec Delgado plus plus
accrocheur que tout à l'heure dans la
mesure où il doit s'accrocher tandis que
R grosse impression il y a quelques
instants il a mal manœuvré ses
dérailleurs et a été bloqué sur place a
perdu une dizaine de mètres il est
revenu à la hauteur de Delgado dans une
facilité qui nous a autant frappé avec
Ron Poulidor que celle tellement visible
et tellement énorme qu'il avait produite
tout à l'heure pour rejoindre Delgado
dans le col du Glandon et le battre au
sommet au sprint oui r c'est très
impressionnant là mais un autre homme
impressionne également c'est un sec à
l'arrière qui impose un train très
sévère et para et Herrera ont du mal à
le suivre je pense que pinsc aujourd'hui
va réaliser une grande étape et une
formidable performance ce qui nous
amènera évidemment un classement général
complètement bouleversé difficile à
établir en ce moment pins et para le
vainqueur d'hier sont encore roule
encore de conserve semble bien sendant
encore que para a accéléré l'allure
brusquement mais P est capable de
réaliser des jolis petits exploits sur
les démarrages en particulier
se laissera paster Herrera une nouvelle
fois mais occupe quand même la 5e
position alors que tout à l'heure il
naviguait en 20e ou 25e position une
nouvelle fois donc Herrera a laissé
filer et para que pinsek devrait
surveiller enfin il le surveille mais
prendre en chasse au moment où justement
pins à son tour connaît un léger
fléchissement cassure de rythme c'est
une montée pour les poursuivant fa
opérer au train les poursuivant
Jean-Paul virage 13 pour les poursuivant
virage 13 c'està-dire Alvaro pign Denis
et am voilà donc pour les trois cours
suivants nous n'allons pas tarder à les
voir aussi il est bien évident que si
Gérard Rols sur sa moto peut nous
communiquer quelques informations au
sujet de la course de Jean-François
Bernard toujours escorté de lot de
capess et d'un autre coéquipier mais à
plus de 16 minutes du côté du Glandon
tout à l'heure lorsque nous avons rendu
pour la première fois l'antne donc si
Gérard Nou n concernant Jean-François
Bernard qui nous les communique et nous
allons suivre plus spécialement épins et
moté dont on pensait que le
sommet
ici moté pourrait prendre le maillot
jaune maintenant
oui c'est bien compromis pour lui je
pense que Delgado qui est actuellement
est survolté pense justement à ce
maillot jaune mais un autre favori du
Tour de France apparî qui n'était
pratiquement pas cité c'est r bien sûr
et alors je vous invite à regarder il
reste encore 12 çaant dégradant 12
virages comme celui-ci qu'il faut éviter
de prendre la des bien négocié sans
cassure de r vous invite à admirer la
puissance du coup de de R et nous
allons nous le voyons
justement sous la selle de Delgado c'est
ça dénote un homme qui dispose de
réserve d'une force pe commune que doit
découvrir sans doute Delgado Delgado
n'avait sans doute pas au départ du Tour
de France négliger les possibilités de
Ros mais s'attendait-il à une telle
résistance de sa part alors que del
piado s'applique à rester en tête à
imposer une roue d'avance à
Rooks alors nous les quittons pour
l'instant Delgado et Rook qui compte 35
secondes d'avance sur ces trois Pignot
tenis et h et htin qu'on avait pas parlé
jusqu'à présent très fac parler très peu
c'est vrai mais on va prendre l'écart
entre les trois
il a fait s pruv l'année dernière m
habilement sa course non pas en se
ménageant se
[Musique]
montrantyedand pourer
àantz
surch desâs car aujourd'hui c'est la
journée la plus terrible du Tour celle
où ce soir lors de la lecture du
classement on constatera tout simplement
qu'il ne seront plus que qu ou C capable
de gagner impossible de revenir de
l'arrière sil en compte plus de 10
minutes et pourtant il reste une longue
étape de col demain aprèsdemain contre
la montre demain contre la monte en col
et puis dans de jours déjà les
Py la facilité de route très facile je
pense qu'il fait la course d'équipe en
ce moment car il a ten de l'équipe PDM
qui derrière on VO il ne rela pas
Delgado mais enfin il il a pas intérêt
voilà à trop ralentir quand même
d'autant que Delgado ne lui laisse pas
le loisir Rook occupe la 20e place au
classement avec un retard de 3 minutes
47 secondes Delgado était 6e 1 minute 52
alors 32 secondes de retard au virage 11
pour les trois hommes 43 sur
para donc para vient de passer à 43
secondes et nous attendons pas sec que
para vient précisément de lâcher et nous
pouvons déjà vous dire que l'écart donc
entre les homes de tête et sec sera
au-del de la minute voici Hera qui passe
à une minute et 2 secondesa
emble donc les positions sur cetteé de
l'Alp r
Delgado dans l'ordre qu'occupe
actuellement
ensite
in et à plus d'une minute qui revient
sur minute 5 et minute 43ve
dit
28av léèr devant
Clav maintenant
à3 il sontous disure oui oui alors évid
apptien
group
53 et dans quelques instants nous allons
avoir l'écart avec M mais M semble avoir
perdu beaucoup beaucoup de
terrainisb l'attend
pas tout se tout seul tout seul aussi à
l'arrière vous mez que la plupart des
leaders se retrou bien seul en ce moment
alors un peu de compagnie ça ne fait pas
de mal c'est pourquoi
r sach derrière ce sont quelque peu
protégé Delgado Rous ne veut pas passer
ça n pas qu' n soit pas
capable ça nous rappelle la fameuse
ascension pidor en que sur le pu au cou
coude à qui Blu l'autre oui alors que à
l'arrière la pin qui assure l'essentiel
du travail car bien sûr tennis ne le
relait pas et HS en embuscade attention
à son démarrage et Charlie m est passé
au virage 11 avec 2 minutes 30 de retard
sur les hommes de tête ça se
creuse serait étonnant qu'amstin nessaie
pas de démarrer lorsque les deux vont
être rejoints S sont rejoints et à
partir de là oui ben tenis aussi peut
démarrer parce que c'est Pignot qui fait
tout le travail sur l'ascension qui
monte à son train comme il l'avait fait
à l'occasion de la montée du Glandon
vers le col et tenis d'abord d'abord n'a
pas prendre le relais étant donné que
Rook occupant pour la première fois oui
la première place avec une longueur
d'avance sur Delgado doit surprendre
Delgado je le répète et j'insiste sur le
mot c'est une partie de bluff aussi
entre les deux
sachant que l'un veut imposer à
l'autre son action personnelle mais pas
toujours
capable C gu qui accompagne maintenanty
don l'ordre à celui-ci de porter à
l'avance c'estd d'onner chare qui ne
semblait pas au mieux de sa forme
lorsque nous l'avons passé aussi pour
mais sera pas la seule éip ce
so OIG une
[Musique]
relanceier quioccupe la 5 place la 6
place
[Musique]
ex impressionnant de puissance qui
semble monter à son ryth ryth très
soutenu oui avec un développement
peut-être un peu lourd et surtout à la
sortie de ses virages lui comme vous le
disiez il est tout en force tout en
puissance alors il revient pas trop sur
dérailleur je crois qu'on pourrait
acheter un dérailleur à la fin du tour
de France àarin ça sera l'un des moins
usagés je crois je crois qu'il est en
train peut-être de réaliser une des
montées les plus rapides peut-être par
il peut surtout s'il all les trop en
point de M il rejoindre et est débordé
immédiatement mais méfions-nous quand
même de la réaction de tenonis des nom
nouveaux qui interviennent sur cette
montée de l'Alp d'Ise sur celle de de
celui de Delgado évidemment bien connu
dans le passé déjà encore que très jeune
et Rook qui confirme tout son talent
d'homme de classique d'homme complet par
à l'abordage là pour rejoindre les trois
qui n'ont cependant pas marqué un temps
d'arrêt mais qui comme d'autres c'est
bien naturel perd beaucoup de temps à se
ravitailler au bord de la route avec les
boissons rafraîchissantes et il aperçoit
les deuxés ah oui oh là sur le
dérailleur de Para
ouo Herrera perd beaucoup de terrain en
ce moment et Rena Passek est en train de
revenir sur lui
[Musique]
r bien loin de démarrer actuellement
rcontre beaucoup de difficultés pour
suivre Pignot et tenis donc l'allure de
Pignot mais lui aussi s'apparente un peu
au grimpeur colombien effectue des
différences dans l'école un sprint court
il peut revenir et puis après coinc
c'est une nouvelle fois impressionnant
le braquet de parer il doit monter à mon
avis sur le 17 18 dans 30
39ors laiss aucune chance à Ham de
s'accrocher au
portebagage mais encore une fois peut
revenir P tenis suivi de Para et hamstin
ce sont les positions à 20 secondes
environ des deux leaders
Delgado
[Musique]
R
tout le monde du même
coup
positionten
[Musique]
M attention il va passer
vite vainur hier et au terme d'une étape
éblouissante sa fin de course laiss
aucune chance à
personne de manre plus n encore que tout
à l'heureand songe que ce Tour de France
prévoit arrivé au sommet puisque de de N
pas et enfin le pour la prière ascension
qui marque
l'arrivée tout à coup la confirm
ce mais s
àir'osquéationil jusqu cont eff
pourevenir dans le de
dev pas la faire estarr actuementf
de M VO
avec Delgado et ça n'est pas à tenise de
faire le travail oui alors qu'on
retrouve les deux hommes de tête
toujours Delgado ouis s paré à peu près
par une vingtaine de secondes donc en 3e
position para tenis et Pignot et je me
retourne car maintenant hamstetin se
trouve à peu près à 300 m des trois
hommes et il est littéralement à la
dérive ah ça ne pardonne pas lorsque
tout à coup on fléchit il faisait une
bonne impression Amstein et compte tenu
de son expérience dans ce genre
d'arrivée il va quand même se placer
parmi les 7 priers oui mais il a un coup
de trompeur il est tellement
facile on pense qu'il va démarrer qu'il
suit tellement facilement et puis il
craque subitement et c'est ce qui s'est
passé quand à Delgado il navigue un peu
à propos de sa position des mains sur le
guidon voilà confirmer de parfois les
mains au cocotte lorsquil se m en
danseuse et préfère la situation des
bras bien arrondis avec ce mouvement
particulier qui est s C
sur un guidon
étrangement descendant un guidon un peu
spécial oui très
[Applaudissements]
large chacun d' côté de la route r not
au passage